hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming through with another
math video to help you boost your score
in your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this video what
I wanted to show you is how to work with
the ti-83 or ti-84 graphing calculator
to find standard deviation so you
probably learn how to do standard
deviation by hand but you also want to
know how to use your calculator to do
the same thing and I'll just show you
how this works so what we're going to do
here is we're going to go to our
graphing calculators and it's the same
for the ti-83 and ti-84 I'm just using
the ti-84 here but what I want to show
you here is we're going to go to stat
okay right here see where it says stat
okay and then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna go to edit that's the first
one and what you see these lists here if
you want to clear these lists out just
arrow up to the top so I'm just using
the arrow keys and go ahead and hit
clear when you arrow back down it's
gonna clear out that list I'm gonna do
the same thing with list 1 I'm just
gonna hit clear I'm gonna arrow down so
let's just say you wanted to find the
standard deviation for some quiz scores
say the quiz scores are like 5 enter 8 8
9 and 10 so not a lot of data here but I
just want to show you how this works so
then what you want to do is you want to
go back to stat ok you want to go arrow
over to calculate and we're going to
select number one one variable
statistics since we're just working with
just quiz scores just one variable we're
going to select enter you're gonna arrow
down to calculate you can see we're
working with list number one enter and
there you go so if you scroll down you
can see X bar there the one at the top
this represents the the mean the average
it's 8 okay but the one we're going to
be using is the one here with the Sigma
the little circle okay the standard
deviation that's one point six seven so
that gives you an idea of how spread out
the data points are from the mean okay
and if you arrow down there's some other
interesting data as well there's the
number of data points five N equals five
the minimum the first quartile the
medium the third quartile the maximum so
there's a lot of information here but
the one that we're interested in is this
one here Sigma
okay and that gives you the standard
deviation so I hope this video was
helpful for finding the standard
deviation using your ti-83 or ti-84
go ahead and check out some of my other
videos subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you soon